Kris Jenner opens up about her newest
grandson Saint West the baby's getting
you know bigger by the day
the 60 year old momager stepped out in
new york city monday night to celebrate
the launch of Kendall and Kylie a new
fashion line by her two youngest
daughters but before talking fashion
Chris got candid about family
specifically Kim Kanye and their son
saint who all currently live with her in
LA everybody's great you know going a
million miles an hour and the baby's
getting you know bigger by the day and
it's so much fun to watch him grow up so
it's great it's really great having him
there actually I joke and I say winner
that you know but honestly it's so great
having them all there it'd be weird
Vanilli I know I don't know how many
walking right by where is everybody
encouraging her to have another one I no
no not yet between designing and daddy
duty Kanye has been busy but never too
busy to offer up fashion advice he gives
all of us inspiration so really proud
that when he does speak up and say you
know do it like this or do it like that
I think that we all love his advice
because he's so brilliant about it